hey guys I know that for many of you  ninety percent of watching the Rubin  report is about seeing me but there's  about ten percent of you that apparently  just want this in audio form so you  asked and we heard yes oh that is right  as of right now the Rubin report the  full episodes my direct message and our  full interviews are available as an  audio podcast on iTunes I'm pretty sure  for some of you guys you'll be able to  figure out ways to get it off itunes or  stream it or download it or something  it's out there it's audio and now you  can do this on a commute I know you list  me but you could just take a picture of  me and you know make it your screensaver  on your phone and then watch that that  sounds fun